all right so Leatherface is as you can
imagine a problem he is got really
really good range a lot a lot of I can
imagine that chainsaw gives some good
yes a lot of very basic mix-ups
like I said a lot of range she can
attack from kind of sweet distance when
other characters cannot he's got a lot
of he's got like a long range overhead
his sweep attack is a little long as
Street sweeps in the game his down for
attack is one of those fastest in the
game even those little low posts have a
lot of range so you know he's not really
a finesse character but he plays his
game and uh range a lot of characters
don't because of this chainsaw now you
say you thought a finesse character you
saying that because you also said that I
should play him easy to play and not is
code though it's fun so the ground
sparks actually three stands the by the
sparks bigotry stand and then you get
your help sure it's what you'll use and
in the middle of a combo to kind of
bigger big damage and then the X version
that's pretty cool because he holds it
and then he goes for now has armor
mm-hmm
so they can shoot like a projectile or
eby's as a wake up attack and you can
arm recruit and then you have a couple
options you can choose to not go forward
or you can go for it really fast if you
want now is this is this the ground
sparks are they in every yeah yeah these
are all the variation like default
element the common would come and that's
the word you're looking for
yes so that's kind of his key combo
starter then he has this overhead slash
where he goes into this animation it's a
pretty quick move it's an overhead so
you can mix it up with your lows and
it's like your combo under and the ex1 a
little bit longer it has armor so it's a
really good wakeup attack yeah he's
doing a it's doing good damage there
unlike
with minimal attacks for the most part
yeah Leatherface is not a guy that's
gonna do like a hunnert hit combos but
he hits hard absolutely so that's just a
it's a chainsaw which is a low attack he
goes really far the ex1 has armor and it
knocks them down and it kind of
complements the overhead move so you
know when you're around this range and
if you think sub-zero is gonna go on you
can use that as your Oberon Rubin um
blood just gets knocked down he could
mix up overhead armor moon or below
armor moon
sure wait go yeah or even just plain
kind of initial game all right what else
we got here
then he has the spin move oh that's
that's classic leather have any sense
finest and the ex1 is pop-up yeah god
bless that that's another move that you
can use at this range that's really
really strong you know it's not the
fastest world but you get to play your
game in a range they can so it's really
good awesome and then he has an anti-air
chainsaw move if you jump in you can use
it and you can use it in combos so in
the corner you can use it to extend your
combos if you want you can use it like
more than once behind the curtain and
here you go throw it's one of my
favorite girls in the game awesome
yeah and so what do we have special to
the killer O'Berry a killer is all based
around circumstance you do the stance
it's down back and on that Sackett he
goes in the stance he runs it and then
you have three different moves you can
do it from it he's got this rush move
we're here fine yeah that's not the most
you the most terrifying one yeah no oh
yeah look at that yeah so that goes
almost the way all the way across it's
pretty quick and you can meter burn it
- extender combos if you could meet her
if I meet her Bertha correctly but I did
that's why you're no longer knocking bit
yes there you go and then you have a big
combo extent oh my gosh he also has this
overhead move which is the fact he just
quickly goes crazy with it
so you know what is they well um insane
I think boss battle Reese and them in
the meter burn one he does a lot more
damage
- that's blood that's the one we even
have in a match if I have trouble yeah
because when he does that you can you
know meter burn and I'm always letting
go a block early but you get that one
more right because that but then yeah if
you're mashing you're trying to punish
that next one comes out and you're
screwed and he could use that you see
they don't fall down so a letter face
could run up and continue mix up and
that is probably the scariest one and I
think this one really nails kind of what
it's like to fight a war character be
unblockable across the screen and this
move is unblockable it doesn't really
good struck a damage now that's pretty
terrible yeah so you can use this in mix
up so you can kind of go into the stance
and then they want to block your attacks
because they're worried about the first
two and that's where you going to
blockable right then you get wise to
that you're gonna start trying to attack
them out of it and then you go for the
insane oh gosh you can also meter burn
this also can absorb projectiles you can
if you shoot a nice blast of course when
he's when he was doing good at full
screen if you could do when you do their
block ball he can freeze you here though
right so it's more like you'll use it
and you'll hope for the
deer-in-headlights thing where the
opponent is gonna freak out ranek try to
block because they're worried about this
one yeah it's not like people are gonna
be like oh they're gonna be spamming
that move if you're fullscreen and
you're going in sub-zero and you slide
it's over yeah you definitely lower face
players are gonna have to mix up all
three but wait there's more oh there's
more
now you're wise to that and you're
looking the slide right wise to that I'm
looking
slide well you can cancel ah you can
cancel the one attack oh well are you
gonna say them yeah you can cancel the
one you can cancel blockable and you can
take them out okay so that's really
killer stance you know it's all about
the stance sure and that's uh that's
pretty much it
great yeah cool playing Steve here for a
moment
absolutely and I will look at a piece of
paper sure just as you do tried to see
why no book shorts deal is the
restaurant one it's all based on up
close and personal he is a lot of his
normal attacks on his combos get
replaced with these really quick hammer
moves he gets a really fast overhead he
gets this mover he punched you in the
gut every stand I like to point out one
thing too with Leatherface each one of
his variations has a different skin as
well as you'll notice in the last time
he had a different apron and a different
costume in general in this same same
face and even the next variation that we
show off will also have a different
costume effects yeah so this one's all
about like you know if if killer was
about kind of this range this one's all
about being up close he his new special
moves are you get to this overhead bot a
very quick jumping over at is it is it
called overhead bump in the it is not
called that but I call it the jump pop
jump okay with community I'll be happy
the jump Bob Jim yes one has armor and
pops them up for a combo jump pop pop up
yeah that's a jump pop up and then he
gains a new chainsaw move where he x1
knocks you down it's like a comm wonder
the ex1
knocks them down for a little bit longer
sure and he gains another chance I'll
move where he grinds them and then
personally my favorite Leatherface move
he gains and probably the biggest thing
about butcher is he gains a command rack
which is a you know a tribute to the
first movie absolutely awesome moving
that staggers them and you can you NEX
that one you can and he knocks them down
and it has armor and the cool thing
about the butcher come and grab it is
one of the fastest command grabs in the
game really it's really really fast
really effective so he's got a lot of
really fast moves yes he's got the fast
blows he's got the fast man grabs
awesome so yeah I think butcher will be
one if you really want to get up closer
if it's an opponent who does well
against the chainsaw moves you can go in
butcher what are you doing I'm just
trying to try some sub-zero stuff
irreplacable do I do this freeze here
like that that's pretty cool that's
different I think that's me yeah I been
there all along I just said no who knows
right yeah so that's pretty much it for
that one right yes all right great all
right pretty lady then this is my
favorite one um my favorite thing that
Leatherface does is during one of his
fatalities he does me go I love his
voice so yeah pretty lady is it is the
opposite of butcher butcher was all
about up close and personal pretty lady
is the hearts owner mother face real
quick a stream chat update okay I guess
they saw something new with unbreakable
sub-zero really yeah they're good
they're either going prison his costume
must have been continued pretty lady
alright got a new have a nice shoes on
yeah these came back for my mine's a
creepy wedding Sunday church my desk oh
maybe all of the FISC oh look at the
loafers man I might face subtle detail
he's not wearing socks yes
so yeah pretty lady beans a bunch of
really really strong fast projectiles
because I mean if you had a chainsaw
wouldn't you throw it yeah he gets a
straight one did he get the exit do a
lot of damage she gets a low 100 even
gets
doesn't he get an air street one two yes
you know oh my gosh
that's that's that's good I don't think
I could throw up James are actually you
know a lot of people have said
Leatherface how does he compete with
these supernatural guys it takes a lot
of arm strength if she saw like that
Emily that yeah so let face up pretty
lady my opinion becomes honestly one of
the best keep up characters in the game
I actually think there are really really
strong projectiles so it can really
really complements the chainsaw goals to
play from this range like the opponent
has a hard time for full screen because
of these and then even when you get in
here
you know he's still gonna do really well
right cool oh oh there we go
I wanted to see if I could do anything
with Grand Master in that clock
[Music]
you